ist ja kaum noch zu hause und deshalb
habe ich mir jemand als tochter
engagiert
das ist ja gut dann ruft du dich auch
zum geburtstag ich mir da keinen stress
mehr toni erdmann ist eine komödie von
made wie lange willst bleiben und da es
eine komödie ist geht es einen ganz
schön an die nieren natürlich wie sich
das gehört die muss seine punkte kommen
und da drin rumpeln und so das macht der
film auch ganz gut es geht um einen
vater der seine tochter helfen willst du
mich fertig machen oder was der vater
ist so ein bisschen halb verwendet schon
der ist so ein bisschen in der absender
des lebens und die tochter arbeitet für
eine consulting-firma die für andere
firmen im grunde rechtfertigen muss dass
leute entlassen werden und sie
arbeiteten bukarest der vater kommt sie
besuchen sie braucht seine hilfe
natürlich nicht
und dann kommt er wieder zurück in einer
verkleidung das heißt er spielt eine
rolle in der rolle diese rolle die er
spielt ist das monster das heißt durch
die monster fresse toni erdmann wünsche
mir ein vater geht da bin ich nicht so
richtig in diese monster fresse zwingt
die tochter sich von ihr helfen zu
lassen einfach dadurch dass zum beispiel
die probleme bei dem man hilfe braucht
von diesem toni erdmann einfach erzeugt
marinade hat schon früher filme gemacht
und deren blick auf die menschen war so
ein bisschen auer mensch diese menschen
das sind ja irgendwie auch arme würste
und so und finstere figuren und was ich
damals noch nicht geahnt habe ist dass
man das nur noch lustig finden muss und
man hat sofort eine großartige komödie
das heißt es stimmt ja die menschen sind
ja wirklich auf eier und in diesem film
sind sie halt auch war ja auf eine art
der sie weder demontiert und irgendwie
preisgibt allgemeinen verachtung noch
unterschätzt dass sie tatsächlich
tierisch einander waffe lauten also du
kannst schon sagen dass du dass du mein
vater bist aber
vielleicht dass du müde bist weil du
viel kultur programm gemacht hast es war
ganz interessant dass auf dem filmfest
in cannes wo er gezeigt wurde
nicht nur deutsche leute kritikerinnen
kritiker sondern eben sogar amerikaner
die ja im hinblick darauf was lustig ist
so sehr verwöhnt sind von hoher
professionalität von komischen timing
von all dieser perfektion die sind
hollywood gibt eben meinten das sei nun
wirklich in sonnen aufgaben erlebnis und
ganz toll und so und wir pfeifen die zu
hause geblieben sind nicht in cannes
waren also so die sitzen bleibe die
eckensteher die um hocker die
stubenhocker
wir waren alles ein bisschen jahren eine
seite alle davon begeistert als wenn
euch irgendwie was erschienen wäre und
so und das wollen wir uns jetzt doch
noch mal in ruhe angucken wenn das dann
in deutschland irgendwie presse
verbesserte erdmann pressevorführung und
dann kam wieder alle raus und sagt also
schlag nicht tot aber es war das denn
jetzt
wir sind eigentlich immer noch in dieser
phase das was war das jetzt und jetzt
kann das buch gekommen auch schön in
dieser phase das was ist das denn jetzt
so in 20 jahren oder so unterhalten wir
uns dann nochmal drüber dass da nicht
mal was passiert ist anderen leuten den
fuß gesunder zu schieben
gar kein frühstück